I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Welcome to The Office, ladies. Welcome everybody.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金赛。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们正在为您制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会剖析《办公室》的一集，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室》女士。欢迎来到《办公室》女士。欢迎大家。
Today we're talking about the episode Sexual Harassment. Oh, it's a doozy. And if you're listening with your kids, we're going to try to keep it clean, folks. Yeah. Maybe you want to pre-screen this one. Yeah. I mean, the subject matter alone. I know.
今天我们要聊的是《性骚扰》这一集。哦，这集可真是个狠角色。如果你是和孩子们一起听，我们要尽量保持内容纯洁，各位。是的。也许你想先筛选一下这一集。是的。我是说，光是这个主题就……我知道。
Well, they had to walk a line when they were writing and making this episode and we're going to walk a line today. Talking about it. Angela, I see you're eating a pop tart. Yes, I am. It's a brown sugar pop tart. Brown sugar? I didn't know cinnamon or brown sugar.
好吧，他们在编写和制作这一集时必须把握好分寸，我们今天也要把握好分寸。聊聊这一集。安吉拉，我看到你在吃果酱馅饼（Pop-Tart）。是的，我在吃。这是红糖口味的。红糖？我不知道是肉桂还是红糖。
It has some brown icing on it. I think it's the cinnamon brown sugar pop tart. Am I right, guys, in the booth? Yeah, it's the cinnamon brown sugar pop tart. This has been a sticking point in my friendship with Angela for a long time, which is that she can eat things like pop tarts, donuts, pancakes for breakfast. This is a bad time for me to tell you. I also had two muffins before the pop tart.
上面有棕色的糖霜。我想是肉桂红糖口味的。我说的对吗，录音室里的伙计们？是的，是肉桂红糖口味的。这长期以来一直是我和安吉拉友谊中的一个症结，那就是她早餐可以吃像果酱馅饼、甜甜圈、煎饼之类的东西。现在告诉你这个时机不太好。我在吃果酱馅饼之前还吃了两个松饼。
It is. It is. All right, guys. Today is Sexual Harassment, season two, episode two. This was written by BJ Novak and directed by Ken Kwapis. You've probably heard those names before. I want to point out in my first fast fact that BJ Novak wrote Diversity Day and Ken Kwapis directed it.
确实是。确实是。好了，伙计们。今天是《性骚扰》，第二季第二集。这一集由BJ·诺瓦克编剧，肯·卡皮斯执导。你们可能以前听过这些名字。我想在我的第一个速记事实中指出，BJ·诺瓦克写了《多元日》，而肯·卡皮斯执导了那一集。
So they already had a little bit of a great back and forth. Yes, they are paired together again. I guess Greg assigned BJ the script of Sexual Harassment because of the good job he had done on Diversity Day. On touchy subjects. Yes. Oh, well, and then Ken was asked to direct it. I think it makes sense.
所以他们之前已经有过一次很棒的合作了。是的，他们又被配对在一起了。我想格雷格把《性骚扰》的剧本交给BJ，是因为他在《多元日》中表现出色。处理棘手的主题。是的。哦，好吧，然后肯被邀请执导这一集。我觉得这很有道理。
Ken Kwapis is such a gentleman. BJ is so smart. He's able to walk that line so well. I think this was the perfect coupling to bring this episode to life. Here's a quick summary for this episode. When an upper level manager is let go because of sexual harassment, corporate requires everyone in the company to undergo sexual harassment training. Michael's crude friend, Todd Packer, comes into the office and starts harassing everyone.
肯·卡皮斯真是位绅士。BJ非常聪明。他能很好地把握那个分寸。我认为这是让这一集栩栩如生的完美组合。这是这一集的简要总结。当一位高层经理因性骚扰被解雇时，公司要求公司里的每个人都必须接受性骚扰培训。迈克尔粗俗的朋友托德·帕克来到办公室，开始骚扰每个人。
Kind of a two for there. There you go. In years later, we would have our own seminars that NBC would have us attend. We've talked about this, and they would use clips from this episode of what not to do at work. And other episodes. And other episodes. We're like, oh, hey, it's us again. Oh, yeah, no one should be doing that.
算是一箭双雕吧。就是这样。多年后，我们自己也参加了NBC要求我们参加的研讨会。我们聊过这个，他们会使用这一集的片段作为工作中不该做的事情的例子。还有其他剧集。还有其他剧集。我们当时想，哦，嘿，又是我们。哦，是的，没人应该那样做。
OK, OK, good. And also, after reading the script, the network originally wanted to air sexual harassment as our season premiere. First season two. I know. Probably good that we eased into that one. It is because this brings me to my second fast fact, which is that this episode originally aired with a warning.
好的，好的，很好。而且，在阅读剧本后，电视网最初想把《性骚扰》作为我们第二季的首播集。第一季第二季。我知道。可能我们慢慢进入状态比较好。确实，因为这让我想到了我的第二个速记事实，那就是这一集最初播出时带有警告。
It did? Yes, which is very unusual for network television. Oh, I didn't know that. It aired within a warning before the episode that said this episode contains adult content and subject matter. Oh. Yeah. And you know why?
真的吗？是的，这在电视网中非常罕见。哦，我不知道。它在播出前有一个警告，说这一集包含成人内容和主题。哦。是的。你知道为什么吗？
All right, parents, this is where you're going to want to start. Maybe maybe put the earmuffs on, earmuffs, earmuffs on the kids. It all came down to the word boner. Yes, with Phyllis. With Phyllis. The scene with Phyllis at the end when Steve says something like, no, I'm just afraid I'll get a boner. The network wanted to change it to I'm afraid I'll get a shwing.
好了，家长们，这就是你们需要开始注意的地方了。也许，也许给孩子们戴上耳罩，耳罩，给孩子们戴上耳罩。这一切都归结于“硬挺”（boner）这个词。是的，和菲利斯有关。和菲利斯有关。最后菲利斯的那一幕，当史蒂夫说类似“不，我只是怕我会硬挺”的话时。电视网想把它改成“我怕我会起反应”（shwing）。
And they, what is it, Wayne's World? Yeah, NBC is like, let's make it Wayne's World. Let's make it a shwing. I'm afraid I'll get a shwing. Yeah. And BJ fought to keep boner in the episode. The warning was their way of having a compromise. We were surprised that Cluterus made it in the episode.
他们，这是什么，《韦恩的世界》吗？是的，NBC就像是，让我们把它变成《韦恩的世界》吧。让我们把它变成“起反应”。我怕我会起反应。是的。BJ极力争取在剧中保留“硬挺”这个词。警告是他们达成妥协的方式。我们很惊讶“阴蒂”（Clitoris）这个词竟然出现在了剧中。
I mean, there's a whole runner with a blow-up doll. I mean, right? You're Pam's supposed to kiss a blow-up doll. There's, to me, many red flags here. A lot of stuff happening. But they got stuck on boner. They got stuck on boner. Sorry.
我是说，有一个关于充气娃娃的完整情节。我是说，对吧？帕姆本该亲吻一个充气娃娃。对我来说，这里有很多危险信号。发生了很多事情。但他们卡在了“硬挺”这个词上。他们卡在了“硬挺”上。抱歉。
Oh, boy. There's too many. That's what she says in this episode. OK, parents. That could be a drinking game for this episode. Wow. We don't condone that. This is mature.
哦，天哪。太多了。那是她在这一集中说的话。好的，家长们。这可以成为这一集的饮酒游戏。哇。我们不纵容那样做。这是成熟的内容。
We don't. OK. But even still, even with the warning, there was one network in Kentucky that refused to air this episode. Oh, really? Yeah. So we?
我们不纵容。好的。但即便如此，即使有警告，肯塔基州还是有一个电视网拒绝播出这一集。哦，真的吗？是的。所以我们？
Sorry, Kentucky. We got pulled off the air. You can watch it on Netflix right now, folks in Kentucky. That is so funny to me, because the word boner, sorry to go back there, is so funny, Phyllis's reaction to the word boner. Yes. It wouldn't be the same if it was shwing.
抱歉，肯塔基州。我们被停播了。肯塔基州的朋友们，你们现在可以在Netflix上看了。这对我来说太搞笑了，因为“硬挺”这个词，抱歉又提到了，太搞笑了，菲利斯对这个词的反应。是的。如果改成“起反应”就不会有同样的效果了。
It wouldn't be the same. It wouldn't be the same. And for me, what made that moment funny was Phyllis. Her look to Michael when he said it was hilarious. So, OK. Moving on. We can talk more about that scene later in the episode. We can really.
不会是一样的。不会是一样的。对我来说，让那一刻变得好笑的是菲利斯。当迈克尔说出那个词时，她看向迈克尔的表情太搞笑了。所以，好的。继续。我们可以在这一集的后面再聊聊那一幕。我们真的可以。
I have a lot to say about that scene. Oh, gosh. More? OK. My third fast fact is that we get to meet Todd Packer finally. The Todd Packer in the flesh comes into the office played by Dave Kekner. OK, so I have known Dave Kekner.
关于那一幕我有很多话要说。哦，天哪。还有更多？好的。我的第三个速记事实是我们终于见到了托德·帕克。由戴夫·科克纳饰演的托德·帕克本尊来到了办公室。好的，所以我认识戴夫·科克纳。
Oh, my gosh, maybe 16 years. I've known him a really long time. We met back at Improv Olympic. He had taken Second City in Chicago, and he knew Steve from Second City and Nancy, Steve's wife, Nancy. I called Dave last night, and I was like, Dave, we're going to do sexual harassment.
哦，天哪，大概16年了吧。我认识他很久了。我们在即兴奥林匹克（Improv Olympic）认识的。他在芝加哥上过第二城（Second City），他从第二城认识史蒂夫，还有史蒂夫的妻子南希。我昨晚给戴夫打了电话，我说，戴夫，我们要聊《性骚扰》那一集。
And he was like, do you have people come in the booth? I was like, we do, Dave. Can you come in tomorrow? And he's like, nah, I'm working. I was like, OK. And then I said, oh, Dave, can I record our conversation? He was like, yeah, sure. Tell me when you're ready to go.
他说，你们录音室里有人吗？我说，有的，戴夫。你明天能来吗？他说，不，我在工作。我说，好的。然后我说，哦，戴夫，我可以录下我们的谈话吗？他说，可以，当然。准备好了告诉我。
Oh, this is great. Yes, it's great. So I did the swipe up on my iPhone, you know what your flashlight is? Sure. You know, underneath, like, by your flashlight? I know my phone. OK, there's a little record button.
哦，这太棒了。是的，太棒了。所以我用iPhone向上滑动，你知道手电筒在哪里吗？当然。你知道，在下面，就在手电筒旁边？我了解我的手机。好的，有一个小小的录音按钮。
OK. So I hit the record button. I was like, let's do this. I feeling like this isn't going where we're hoping. OK, Dave and I talked for half an hour. Yeah. I have 30 minutes of me filming my screen with no sound. OK.
好的。所以我按下了录音按钮。我说，开始吧。我感觉这事情没往我们希望的方向发展。好的，戴夫和我聊了半小时。是的。我有30分钟我录制屏幕但没有声音的视频。好的。
OK. It's a record button. How is I supposed to know it doesn't record sound? I don't know where to begin with this one. Is it because I'm 100 years old? Well, it's just that that's sort of like when my mom wrote me my first email. Yeah.
好的。那是录音按钮。我怎么会知道它不录声音？我不知道该从哪里开始说这个。是因为我100岁了吗？好吧，这有点像我妈妈第一次给我写电子邮件的时候。是的。
She called me on the phone and said, why haven't you responded to my email that I sent you? Yeah. And I said, well, I never got your email. What email address did you send it to? And she said, I sent it to you. I sent it to Jenna. And I said, I don't understand.
她给我打电话说，为什么你没回复我发给你的邮件？是的。我说，好吧，我没收到你的邮件。你发到哪个邮箱地址了？她说，我发给你了。我发给珍娜了。我说，我不明白。
And she said, I opened the email box. And it said, too, and I wrote Jenna. She just sent an email to Jenna. That is very similar to what you've done here with the record button on your phone a little bit. Come on. A little bit. Wait a minute.
她说，我打开邮件框。上面写着“收件人”，我写了珍娜。她只是给“珍娜”发了一封邮件。这和你刚才在手机上按录音按钮的操作非常相似。拜托。有一点点。等一下。
It's kind of. Anyway, whatever, guys. The long story short here is, Dave, thank you so much for talking to me last night for half an hour. And I wrote down everything we talked about because it didn't record. You do have a gazillion note cards today. I have.
有点像。不管怎样，伙计们。长话短说，戴夫，非常感谢你昨晚和我聊了半小时。我写下了我们谈论的所有内容，因为没录上。你今天确实有一大堆笔记卡片。我有。
Angela had to move seats because she has so many note cards. I have so many note cards. I have lots of little fun tidbits from Dave, but I'll save those as we go. OK, that's great. Something I'd like to expand on is what you were saying about Steve Carell starting at Second City in Chicago.
安吉拉不得不换座位，因为她有太多的笔记卡片。我有太多的笔记卡片。我有很多来自戴夫的小趣闻，但我会在我们聊的过程中慢慢分享。好的，那太棒了。我想展开聊聊你刚才说的关于史蒂夫·卡瑞尔在芝加哥第二城开始职业生涯的事。
I think a lot of people don't realize the long journey that a lot of us took before we landed on the office, and in particular, Steve Carell. He was doing comedy in Chicago on Second City for a very, very long time. And then he and his wife, Nancy, they moved to New York City because she had an audition for Saturday Night Live. And she got it.
我想很多人没有意识到我们很多人在进入《办公室》之前所经历的漫长旅程，特别是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。他在芝加哥的第二城做喜剧做了非常非常久。然后他和他的妻子南希搬到了纽约市，因为她要去参加《周六夜现场》的试镜。她成功了。
She did. Her and Dave were on Saturday Night Live together. So they had known each other for a really long time and journeyed through quite a bit. And Steve was really excited. He is actually the one who pitched Dave to Greg for Todd Packer. He was really like, you've got to cast Dave Keckner.
她确实成功了。她和戴夫一起在《周六夜现场》工作。所以他们认识很久了，一起经历了很多。史蒂夫当时非常兴奋。实际上是他向格雷格推荐戴夫出演托德·帕克。他真的说，你一定要选戴夫·科克纳。
They had just done Anchorman together. And he just knew that they'd be off to the races and it'd be so much fun. And their dynamic in Anchorman was amazing. Their chemistry there was amazing. But it makes sense because they had been schlepping through Chicago to New York to LA together doing comedy for close to 15 years.
他们刚一起拍完《王牌播音员》。他知道他们会一拍即合，会非常有趣。他们在《王牌播音员》里的互动太棒了。他们的化学反应太棒了。但这很有道理，因为他们一起在芝加哥、纽约和洛杉矶摸爬滚打做了近15年的喜剧。
Oh, yeah. They'd known each other for so long. And you were in those circles, Angela. I never got into that. I never did the comedy improv sketch comedy thing. Yes. I had met Dave years ago at Improv Olympic out here in Los Angeles.
哦，是的。他们认识太久了。安吉拉，你当时也在那些圈子里。我从来没进去过。我从来没做过即兴喜剧或小品喜剧。是的。我多年前在洛杉矶的即兴奥林匹克见过戴夫。
It was called Iowest and he was part of a phenomenal improv show called Beer Shark Mice. These guys were amazing. They were like the best of the best. It would sell out. It would be standing room only. They were amazing. It was Mike Coleman, Pat Finn, Neil Flynn, and Pete
它叫Iowest，他是那个了不起的即兴表演秀“啤酒鲨鱼鼠”（Beer Shark Mice）的一员。这些家伙太棒了。他们是精英中的精英。门票总是售罄。只能站着看。他们太棒了。有迈克·科尔曼、帕特·芬恩、尼尔·弗林和皮特·霍尔尼、戴夫·科克纳，还有保罗·瓦伦考特。他们简直太出色了。
Holney, Dave Keckner, and then also Paul Valencourt. They were just phenomenal. Wow, what a show. It was great. So like, listen, if you're an improv nerd out there, these guys are the best of the best. I was working in the light booth. I was in charge of calling their lights.
哇，真是场精彩的演出。太棒了。所以，听着，如果你是个即兴表演迷，这些家伙就是精英中的精英。我在灯光室工作。我负责给他们打灯光。
And I was really intimidated because the person in the light booth makes it fade to black when you feel that the show has wrapped up. So what? It's kind of on you to decide. It's on me. And here I am. You're like the person lowering the curtain
我当时真的很紧张，因为灯光室的人要在觉得演出结束时把灯光调暗。所以呢？决定权在你手里。在我手里。我当时就在那儿。你就像那个在演出结束时放下幕布的人。
at the end of the show. Yes. And I'm just like a newbie at the theater. Really, you're going to trust me? Was there no one else? And so I was calling lights and I really felt like the show wrapped up. And it was about 30 minutes.
是的。我只是剧院里的一个新手。真的，你要信任我吗？没有别人了吗？所以我当时在打灯光，我真的觉得演出结束了。大概30分钟。
And I pulled it to black. And they were like, what? And then afterwards, Dave and everyone was like, Ange, we had a whole nother round to go. You called the lights way too soon. And I was like, I am so sorry. I am so sorry. I felt so horrible.
我把灯光调黑了。他们当时说，什么？然后演出结束后，戴夫和每个人都说，安吉，我们还有整整一轮要演呢。你太早调暗灯光了。我说，我太抱歉了。我太抱歉了。我感觉糟透了。
All right, so it's the next week. And Dave comes up to me and says, Ange, let us go about 45 minutes tonight. I'm like, OK, Dave, got it. Set my timer. You set a timer. I love that. That's very Jenna of you.
好吧，到了下周。戴夫走过来对我说，安吉，我们今晚要演45分钟。我说，好的，戴夫，明白了。设置了我的计时器。你设置了计时器。我喜欢这个。这很“珍娜”。
Thank you. Yes. I didn't want to get it wrong. So anyway, I'm up in the light booth at 39 minutes. I thought they had their out, Jenna. OK. I did not pull lights. You did?
谢谢。是的。我不想再搞砸了。总之，我在39分钟时在灯光室。我以为他们已经演完了，珍娜。好的。我没调暗灯光。你调了吗？
No. No. And then they went to 45 minutes. And then it was almost an hour. What? I didn't want to pull the lights. I was too nervous. I don't know.
没有。没有。然后他们演到了45分钟。然后快一个小时了。什么？我不想调暗灯光。我太紧张了。我不知道。
I froze. They're probably just out there just flailing on stage. It was getting awkward. And Dave walks backstage. And someone had left, I don't know, a spare tire to like a truck or a Jeep. It was enormous. So Dave gets this giant tire, and he rolls it
我僵住了。他们可能只是在台上胡乱表演。气氛变得很尴尬。戴夫走到后台。有人留下了，我不知道，一个卡车或吉普车的备用轮胎。它巨大无比。所以戴夫拿了这个巨大的轮胎，把它滚过舞台滚进了观众席。
across the stage into the audience. And he's like, that's our show, you guys. And I was like, oh, crap. Oh, crap. When the tire went across the stage, did you finally go to Black Ange? I did. OK.
他说，这就是我们的表演，伙计们。我说，哦，糟了。哦，糟了。当轮胎滚过舞台时，你终于调暗灯光了吗，安吉？我调了。好的。
So you got his signal then. I got it. I got it, Dave. The tire. I got it. And I went backstage. I was like, you guys. And we all started cracking up.
所以你收到他的信号了。我收到了，我收到了，戴夫。那个轮胎。我收到了。我走到后台。我说，你们这些家伙。我们都开始大笑起来。
And they still talk about it. They still talk about the tire. Anyway, I just love those guys so much. And believe it or not, I did call lights for them a few more times until they got their official person. But that is how I met Dave Keckner. Didn't Greg Daniels go to a few of those shows? I mean, maybe not Dave's in particular, but.
他们现在还在谈论这件事。他们还在谈论那个轮胎。总之，我太爱这些家伙了。信不信由你，我确实又为他们打了几次灯光，直到他们有了正式的人选。但这就是我认识戴夫·科克纳的方式。格雷格·丹尼尔斯没去看过几场演出吗？我是说，也许不是戴夫那场，但是。
Oh, no. Greg loved supporting small improv theaters. And a lot of improvisers ended up on our show. So I know Rainn Wilson would make fun of me. But I'd be like, oh, whoever actor is showing up. I did a Sunday show with them. And he'd be like, did you do improv with them, Angela? I'm like, yes, Rainn.
哦，不。格雷格喜欢支持小型即兴剧院。很多即兴表演者最终都加入了我们的剧组。所以我知道雷恩·威尔逊会取笑我。但我会说，哦，不管哪个演员出现。我和他们一起做过周日演出。他会说，安吉拉，你和他们一起做过即兴表演吗？我说，是的，雷恩。
Well, Rainn and I were the two classically trained theater actors in the group. Oh, don't we know it. I heard quite a bit about it. Yes. All right. Before things take a turn here, maybe we should go to a break. Yeah, let's go to a break.
好吧，雷恩和我当时是组里唯二受过古典戏剧训练的演员。哦，我们都知道。我听过不少关于这个的事。是的。好了。在事情发生转折之前，也许我们应该休息一下。是的，让我们休息一下。
And we're back talking about the sexual harassment episode. Here we go. Here we go. Buckle in, everyone. Buckle in, as they say. In rewatching this episode, Angela, I was very uncomfortable. Yeah. I was more squirmy during this than Diversity Day.
我们回来了，继续聊《性骚扰》那一集。开始了。开始了。系好安全带，各位。系好安全带，正如他们所说。在重温这一集时，安吉拉，我感到非常不舒服。是的。比起《多元日》，我在看这一集时更坐立难安。
Well, yeah, I mean, I don't know. They're both equally squirmy for me, for sure. But then I was squirmy during Hot Girl. I think that I had forgotten how really cringy and uncomfortable the show can get sometimes. Oh, we pushed it. We pushed it to the line and then went over the line. How did this show get on the air?
好吧，是的，我是说，我不知道。对我来说，它们都同样让人坐立难安。但我看《辣妹》那一集时也坐立难安。我想我忘了这部剧有时会变得多么尴尬和不舒服。哦，我们推到了极限。我们推到了边缘，然后越过了界限。这部剧是怎么播出的？
I mean, I know this particular episode got on with a warning, but in general, what was going on? I don't know. I mean, you know, I grew up overseas, and I grew up with a lot of British television. And they definitely pushed the line. And I think the show was in the spirit of the BBC version. And I don't know.
我是说，我知道这一集是带着警告播出的，但总的来说，当时发生了什么？我不知道。我是说，你知道，我在海外长大，我从小看很多英国电视节目。他们绝对推到了极限。我认为这部剧有BBC版本的精神。我不知道。
I think some of the cringy moments that you end up laughing, I don't know. I love it. I know that Kevin Riley, who was at NBC at the time, was a huge champion for our show. I really credit him with us sticking around. He believed in us. And there were a lot of people there who didn't get it
我想有些尴尬的时刻你最终会笑出来，我不知道。我喜欢它。我知道当时在NBC的凯文·赖利是我们剧集的坚定支持者。我真的认为我们能坚持下来要归功于他。他相信我们。当时有很多人不理解，也不认为这是一个好主意。
and who didn't think that this was a good idea. No, it's true. He fought for us. And when we finally won an Emmy for Best Comedy Ensemble, we all went backstage for photos. And the guys, the cast, picked up Kevin Riley up in the air. And that's the photo that was in the LA Times,
不，这是真的。他为我们而战。当我们最终赢得艾美奖最佳喜剧群戏奖时，我们都去后台拍照。伙计们，演员们，把凯文·赖利举了起来。那张照片登在了《洛杉矶时报》上，因为我们都知道他为我们冒了险。我是说，我会永远感激凯文。这一集以迈克尔走到吉姆的办公桌前看他是否收到了他那搞笑的转发邮件开始。迈克尔有一个谈话头镜头，他宣称自己是转发之王。他说，我喜欢那样做生意。是的。
because we all knew that he put his neck on the line for us. And I mean, I'll always be grateful to Kevin for that. The episode begins with Michael walking up to Jim's desk to see if he has received his hilarious email forward. Michael has a talking head where he declares himself the king of forwards. And he says, that's how I like to do business. Yeah.
我有一个关于幕后时刻的有趣故事，发生在我们拍摄大群戏时，在办公区谈论这些转发邮件。我当时在场吗？你在场。每个人都在场。每个人都在场。凯莉也在场，还在用那个。
I have a funny story about a behind the scenes moment that happened on set while we were filming a big group scene in the bullpen talking about these email forwards. And was I there? You were there. Everyone was there. Everyone was there. Kelly was there, still with an up to.
凯莉变成明迪是哪一集？正是如此。这就是我们需要寻找的。不，所以这是约翰·卡拉辛斯基和我永远不会忘记的一集，因为他差点从椅子上摔下来。在9分16秒，我们在谈论转发邮件。迈克尔真的很生气，因为他们想让他停止做这些事。
When is the episode where Kelly becomes Mindy? Exactly. That's what we need to look for. No, so this is an episode that John Krasinski and I will never forget, because he about fell out of his chair. At nine minutes, 16 seconds, we're talking about the email forwards. And Michael's really upset that they want him to stop doing
我说，我讨厌它们。你发给我这些肮脏的邮件，然后说转发给10个人，否则你会倒霉。对吧？那是我的台词。所以我们为这一幕工作了一段时间。然后我们去吃午饭，然后我们回来了。
this. And I say, I hate them. You send me these filthy emails and you say forward them to 10 people or you'll have bad luck. Right? That's my line. So we had been working on this scene for a while. And then we went to lunch and we came back.
哦，午饭后接着拍戏总是很难。是的。我想大概是下午3点左右。那时候每个人都状态不佳。每个人都累了。人们有点更冲动。是的。
Oh, that's always so hard to pick up a scene with lunch in between. Yes. And I think it was like around 3 o'clock in the afternoon. Everyone's real off at that time. Everyone's a little tired. People are a little bit more punchy. Yeah.
我们在拍大群戏。所以关于我，你应该知道一件事。我出生在路易斯安那州。我的家人来自德克萨斯州和路易斯安那州。我在L前面的元音发音非常非常困难。在《办公室》的职业生涯中，有两次他们差点删掉台词，因为我发不出那个音。有一次他们真的删了。
And we're in a big group scene. So here's the thing you should know about me. I was born in Louisiana. My family's from Texas in Louisiana. I have a really, really hard time saying a vowel in front of an L. And two times in my career on the office, they almost dropped a line because I could not say it. One time they actually did.
我会把那个故事留到以后再说。那是安迪·伯纳德和我之间的戏。我说不出那句台词。我听起来像个乡巴佬，他们就把台词删了。但这一句，我说，我讨厌它们。你发给我这些肮脏的邮件。约翰差点从椅子上摔下来，他说，南方人来了。我说，什么？什么？我甚至没听出来。他说，安吉拉。你们八个人转过头看着我。同时，你们说，你说的是“肮脏”（filthy）。肮脏。
I'll save that story for later. It was between Andy Bernard and myself. I couldn't say the line. I just kept sounding like such a hillbilly that they just dropped the line. But this line, I said, I hate them. You send me these filthy emails. And John about fell out of his chair and he went,
我说，你们怎么发音？你们说，肮脏。我不得不非常专注地发音：肮脏，肮脏。因为我自动想说“肮脏”（filthy）。但某处有我说的片段：你发给我这些肮脏的邮件。约翰笑疯了。你和约翰在剧组关系很好。
the South has arrived. And I was like, what? What? I didn't even hear it. He was like, Angela. And eight of you turned and looked at me. And at the same time, you were like, you said filthy. Filthy.
你们就像大哥哥和小妹妹。太甜了。我喜欢你们的互动。我喜欢，我不知道。你们真的很可爱。你们会互相取笑。我知道。他感觉像我的大哥哥，尽管他比我小。
And I said, how do you say it? And you were like, filthy. And I had to really concentrate filthy, filthy. Because I automatically want to say filthy, filthy. But somewhere there's footage of me saying, you send me these filthy emails. And John lost it. You and John had a great relationship on the show.
是的。但他确实是。他感觉像我取笑的大哥哥。他很喜欢。当我带出南方口音时，他会说，你好。他很喜欢。所以接下来，托德·帕克来到办公室。
You guys were big brother, kid sister. And it was so sweet. I loved your banter. And I loved just, I don't know. You guys were really cute. You would tease one another. I know. He felt like my big brother, even though he is younger than me.
天哪，戴夫·科克纳走进那个房间时，他真的掌控了全场吗？是的。戴夫昨晚在电话里告诉我，他说，托德·帕克进来，炸毁了你们的世界。然后砰，离开了。没有后果。扔麦克风。
Yes. But he did. He felt like my big brother that I teased. And he loved it. When I slipped into Southern drawl, he'd be like, hello. He loved it. So next up, Todd Packer comes in the office.
是的。回头见。然后他就走了。我有一个关于戴夫的小趣闻。哦，告诉我。好的，戴夫告诉我他实际上试镜过迈克尔·斯科特。什么？是的。
And boy, does Dave Keckner own a room when he enters that room? Yes. Dave told me last night on the phone, he said, Todd Packer just comes in and blows up your world. And then kaboom, leaves. No consequences. Mic drop.
他认识格雷格·丹尼尔斯很多年了。他为格雷格在《山丘之王》的一位编剧拍过试播集。所以他认识格雷格很久了。他们让他来试镜迈克尔·斯科特。他说，安吉，我当时沉迷于BBC版本。我脑子里只有瑞奇·热维斯。我没法用别的方式演。
Yeah. See you later. And then he's out. I have a little tidbit about Dave. Oh, tell me. OK, so Dave told me he actually auditioned for Michael Scott. What? Yes.
所以他模仿了一点瑞奇。是的。我想很多人来试镜时都那样做了。但史蒂夫没看过那个版本。我想这真的帮助他创造了自己的角色。是的。但他告诉我，当他们让他来演托德·帕克时，他非常兴奋。
He had known Greg Daniels for years. He had done a pilot for one of Greg's writers on King of the Hill. So he knew Greg for a long time. And they brought him in for Michael Scott. And he said, Ang, I was obsessed with the BBC version. And all I had in my head was Ricky Gervais. I couldn't do it any other way.
因为，是的，它是基于BBC版本里的芬奇，对吧？哦，是的。所以在BBC版本里，大卫·布伦特有一个朋友叫克里斯·芬奇。他们叫他芬奇。他是英版里的托德·帕克。基本上，这只是一种单方面的友谊。如果你敢相信，克里斯·芬奇比托德·帕克更糟。他更糟。
So he was doing a little bit of an impersonation of Ricky. Yes. And I think a lot of people did that, that came in. But Steve had not seen it. And I think that really helped him kind of make his own person. Yeah. But he told me when they brought him in for Todd Packer, he was so excited.
如果你看英版，你会觉得不可能比托德·帕克更糟。如果你想看那个，去看看英版。正是如此。戴夫说他非常兴奋能来演托德·帕克，因为他们只是说，戴夫，随便演。他当时就像，哦，我搞得定。我搞得定。
Because, yes, it was based on Finchy, right, in the BBC version. Oh, yeah. So in the BBC version, David Brent has a friend named Chris Finch. And they call him Finchy. And he is the Todd Packer of the British Show. Basically, it's just this one-sided best friendship. And if you can believe, Chris Finch is worse than Todd Packer. He is worse.
他和史蒂夫刚拍完《王牌播音员》，正如我们聊到的。所以他知道这只是玩耍时间。我问戴夫，我说，作为托德·帕克的第一天，你记得什么？他说，我记得剧本。我记得读那个剧本，觉得它太棒了。我想，当你有这么好的剧本时，
If you watch the British Show, you think it can't get worse than Todd Packer. If you're looking for that, check out the British version. Exactly. Dave said that he was so excited to come in for Todd Packer because they were just like, Dave, do whatever. And he just was like, oh, I got this. I got this.
一切皆有可能。我可以去任何地方，因为我手里的东西非常扎实。我说，你即兴发挥了吗？他说，老实说，我不记得了，因为我记得当时觉得剧本太好了。他说，如果你看到感觉很自发的东西，他说托德·帕克的肢体语言很容易。就是他。
Him and Steve had just done Anchorman as we talked about. So he knew it was just going to be playtime. I asked Dave, I was like, what is something you remember about that first day as Todd Packer? And he said, I remember the writing. I remember reading that script and thinking how fantastic it was. And I thought, when you have writing this good,
就是他。是的。你知道，他跟迈克尔做的所有事情，那些肢体动作，那只是戴夫赋予托德·帕克生命。但他真的被剧本的好坏惊呆了。我记得他进来的时候，我真的
anything is possible. I can go anywhere because what I have is so solid. And I said, did you improvise any of that? He said, honestly, I can't remember because I remember thinking the writing was so good. He said, if you see things that feel spontaneous, he said the physicality of Todd Packer is very easy. Is him.
震惊了。为什么？好吧，我们的剧组一直很安静。哦，对。哦，对。他是一股能量的爆发。他太吵了。所以我对他的很多反应都是真实的。
Is him. Yeah. You know, like all the stuff he does with Michael, the physical stuff, that's just Dave bringing life to Todd Packer. But he really just was just blown away by how good the writing was. I remember when he came in, I was legitimately
它们就像，什么？我们为什么要大喊大叫？发生了什么？因为我……太多了。这太哇了。因为我75岁了。我是珍娜·费舍尔。你为什么这么大声？
shocked and stunned. Why? Well, our show had been very quiet. Oh, right. Oh, right. He's just a burst of energy. And he was so loud. And so a lot of my reactions to him are real.
我问戴夫，因为迈克尔有一句台词说托德·帕克是他的BFF，永远的好朋友。我看到了。是的。我说，戴夫，迈克尔怎么会和托德·帕克是最好的朋友？他说了一些我觉得非常甜的话，实际上，对迈克尔很有洞察力。
They're like, what? Why are we shouting? What is happening? Because I'm is a lot. This is so wow. Because I'm 75. I'm Jennifer sure. Why are you being so loud?
他说，哦，安吉拉，他说迈克尔太天真了。他几乎像个孩子。他根本不明白托德·帕克是什么样的人。这是一个多么好的观察。是的。他就像一个小弟弟仰望着某人，也许在未来的某一天，他会看到这是多么不合适。
I asked Dave, because Michael has a line where he says that Todd Packer is his BFF, best friend forever. I saw that. Yeah. And I said, Dave, how does Michael, how is he best friends with Todd Packer? He said something I thought was so sweet, actually, and just insightful into Michael.
但他只是处于这种孩子气的迷恋阶段。哦，我喜欢那个，戴夫·科克纳。好的，现在是时候聊聊那个著名的吉姆谈话头镜头了，那句“什么有两个大拇指，讨厌托德·帕克？这家伙。”好的，那个“什么有两个大拇指，喜欢某某？”的笑话。还有这一集里非常著名的台词，“那是她说的”（That's what she said）。
He said, oh, Angela, he said Michael is so innocent and naive. He's almost childlike. He doesn't get a lot of what Todd Packer is. And how it's such a good observation. Yeah. He's like a little brother looking up to someone and maybe somewhere down the road, he'll see how inappropriate.
那些不是原创笑话。不是我们编的。BJ·诺瓦克没写它们。BJ说那些是他大学时听到的东西。他只是把它们掸掉灰尘，带到了这一集里。然后它们就火了。
But he's just in this childlike enamored phase. Oh, I love that, Dave Kekner. OK, now it's time to talk about that famous gym talking head with the phrase, what has two thumbs and hates Todd Packer, this guy. All right, that joke of what has two thumbs and likes blank. And also, the very famous line from this episode, that's what she said.
我是说，特别是“那是她说的”。我是说，好吧，这很有道理，因为托德·帕克有点像个讨厌的兄弟会成员，对吧？是的。而且“那是她说的”实际上在《周六夜现场》出现过。切维·切斯有个段子说过。它在《韦恩的世界》里。但那个笑话的起源是一个英国笑话。
Those are not original jokes. We did not make those up. BJ Novak did not write them. BJ said those are things that he just heard in college as a college student. And he kind of dusted them off and brought them back to this episode. And then they took off.
但那句话不是“那是她说的”。是什么？那句话是，“正如女演员对主教说的”。你喜欢我的那个吗？那说起来很顺口。是的。但它流行度下降了。它基本上不再使用了，直到瑞奇·热维斯
I mean, especially that's what she said. I mean, well, that makes sense because Todd Packer is sort of like a bratty frat guy, right? Yes. And that's what she said had actually been on SNL. Chevy Chase had a bit where he said it. It was in Wayne's world. But the origin of that joke is a British joke.
把它带了回来。他开始说它。他过去常说，“正如女演员对主教说的”。但它从来没有像“那是她说的”那样流行。好的，这真的跑题了。但你知道，我要给自己弄个“她棚”（she shed）。我要做一个家庭办公室。哦，我做。
But the phrase isn't, that's what she said. What is it? The phrase is, as the actress said to the bishop. Did you like mine? That just rolls off the tongue. Yes. But it dwindled in popularity. It was kind of no longer in use until Ricky Gervais
你一直在谈论这个。我知道。我知道。我一直在网上和Pinterest上看我可以改造成家庭办公室的小棚子。我已经开始了。但我发了一张我和棚子的照片。一位粉丝写道，请叫你的棚子，
brought it back. He used to start saying it. He used to say, as the actress said to the bishop. But it never quite was the same as that's what she said. OK, this is really off topic. But you know, I'm going to have a she shed for myself. I'm making a home office. Oh, I do.
你的“那是她棚”（that's what she shed）。哦，你必须这么叫。我知道。有人现在就开始绣个枕头吧。哦，天哪。我会做的。我喜欢针绣。你会为我绣那个吗？
It's all you talk about. I know. I know. I'm like constantly online and on Pinterest looking at little sheds that I can make into a home office. And I've started the process. But I posted a photo of me with a shed. And a fan wrote in, please call your shed.
“那是她棚”。好的。“那是她棚”。好的。哦，100%。这是这一集里的另一个文化参考。当瑞安带托德·帕克去停车场开车送他去某处时，因为他的酒驾，
Your that's what she shed. Oh, you have to. I know. Someone start needle pointing a pillow right now. Oh my gosh. I'll do it. I like to needle point. Will you needle point me at that?
他有一个WL HUNG。哦，是的。是的，我卡片上有这个。当然，托德·帕克想让每个人都以为那是“Well hung”（大器）。但瑞安说，哦，你是威廉·洪（William Hung）的忠实粉丝吗？千禧一代知道威廉·洪是谁吗？他们懂这个笑话吗？
That's what she shed. OK. That's what she shed. OK. Oh, 100%. Here's another cultural reference from this episode. When Ryan takes Todd Packer down to the parking lot to drive him somewhere because of his DUIs,
我很好奇，因为这在当时是一个非常时髦的笑话。是的。所以威廉·洪是一个老《美国偶像》的梗。他是一个参赛者。他给出了一个糟糕但非常投入的瑞奇·马丁的《She Bangs》的翻唱。是的，第三季。
he has a WL hung. Oh, yes. Yes, I have this on a card. Which, of course, Todd Packer wants everyone to think says, well hung. But Ryan says, oh, are you a big fan of William hung? Do the millennials out there know who William hung is? Do they get this joke?
评委们几乎无法控制自己。保佑他的心。太纯洁了。太诚实了。他就像个工程系学生。他生活中秘密的热情就是这个。好吧，这是在社交媒体之前。然而这却“病毒式”传播了。
I wondered, because this was a very topical of the time kind of joke. Yes. So William hung was an old American Idol reference. He was a contestant. And he gave this horrible, yet very committed rendition of Ricky Martin's she bangs. Yes, season three.
他试镜的视频。他成了一个巨大的轰动。他去巡演了。是的。我想他有自己的TED演讲版本关于成功。但你仍然可以找到它，因为我昨晚看了。我也看了。威廉·洪。
And the judges could barely hold it together. Bless his heart. It was so pure. So honest. He was like an engineering student. His secret passion in life was this thing. Well, this was before social media. And yet this went quote unquote viral.
我不得不查一下，因为当我看这一集时，它勾起了那个记忆。还有，我们能提一下托德·帕克开的是红色敞篷克尔维特吗？我是说，伙计。是的，我想它本该是野马。他们没弄到。所以改成了克尔维特。
This video of him auditioning. And he became a huge sensation. He went on tour. Yeah. I think he had his own version of a TED talk about success. But you can still find it because I watched it last night. I did too. William hung.
好吧，这很完美。确实很完美。在这一集中，我们还得知帕姆的妈妈要来办公室。小帕姆一直偷偷看门口。我知道。太可爱了。帕姆爱她的妈妈。
I had to look it up because when I watched this episode, it brought up the memory of that. Also, can we just mention that Todd Packer drives a red convertible Corvette? I mean, buddy. Yeah, I think it was supposed to be a Mustang. And they couldn't get one. And so it got changed to a Corvette.
这看起来好像我在对帕姆的妈妈刻薄。听我说完。好的，我已经感到防御了。好的。帕姆爱她的妈妈。帕姆的妈妈说，哦，这是你的区域吗？我想，她什么时候没来过办公室？三年了？
Well, it's perfect. It is pretty perfect. Also in this episode, we learned that Pam's mom is coming into the office. And little Pam just keeps sneaking looks at the door. I know. It's so cute. Pam loves her mom.
三年了。你在邓德·米夫林工作。你妈妈从来没来过。这让我很难过。好的。我只是说说。我刚才有个瞬间。我想，为什么她看到帕姆的桌子这么惊讶？
This is going to seem like I'm being snarky to Pam's mom. Hear me out. OK, well, I'm already feeling defensive. OK. Pam loves her mom. Pam's mom says, oh, is this your area? I'm like, when has she never been to the office? In three years?
哇。你很生气。这是一个很好的观点。我是说，她住在城里。我也有很多时间码的东西。哦，给时间码，安吉拉。好的。在5分15秒，伙计们，
Three years. You've been working at Dunder Mifflin. Your mom's never stopped by. It's making me sad. OK. I'm just saying. I just had a moment. I'm like, why is she so surprised to see Pam's desk?
当迈克尔和托比说话时，有一个迈克尔桌子的精彩镜头。我会告诉你你在他桌子上看到了什么。你看到了一个迷你台球桌。你看到了那个银色的球撞击装置。是的。谁会想在桌子上放那个？我不知道。
Wow. You are angry. That's a really good point. I mean, she lives in town. I have a bunch of time code things too. Oh, time code us, Angela. OK. At five minutes, 15 seconds, you guys,
那是干什么用的？我一直想要泥土。那可能是某种禅宗的东西。我猜。珍娜，你看到了他的邓迪奖杯。哦。是的。有一个他邓迪奖杯的精彩镜头。
there is a fantastic shot of Michael's desk when he's talking to Toby. And I'll tell you what all you see on his desk. You see a mini billiards table. You see like the silver ball clacky thingy. Yes. Who ever wants that on their desk? I don't know.
然后看起来像是一个绿色的魔法8号球。在这一幕里，在这一幕的开头，迈克尔手里拿着一支巨大的铅笔。哦，是的。我是说，如果那只是。这家伙喜欢斯宾塞礼品店（Spencer's Gifts）。他喜欢斯宾塞礼品店。那是他最喜欢的商店。
What is that for? I've always wanted dirt. It's probably some kind of zen thing. I guess. Jenna, you see his dundee. Oh. Yes. There's a great shot of his dundee.
但你能想象吗，托比想和他进行严肃的谈话，而迈克尔在整个谈话过程中手里拿着一支超大铅笔。是的。所以，我觉得那是一个很棒的截图。如果你想看迈克尔桌子上的所有东西。好的，安吉，接下来是什么？我还有另一个戴夫·科克纳的故事。
And then what looks like is a green magic eight ball. And in this scene, at the top of the scene, Michael is holding a giant pencil in his hand. Oh, yeah. I mean, if that's just. This guy loves a Spencer's GIFs. He loves a Spencer's GIFs. It's his favorite store.
哦，太棒了。这是你昨晚没在手机上录下来的另一个故事吗？是的，珍娜，是。好的，谢谢。非常感谢。让我们听听。当戴夫接到电话说他们
But can you imagine, Toby wants to have a serious conversation with him, and Michael is holding an oversized pencil throughout the conversation. Yes. So that, I thought, was just a great, great screen grab. If you want to see all the things on Michael's desk. OK, Ange, what's next? I have another Dave Kekner story.
想让他来演托德·帕克时，你猜他在哪？在哪？他在加拿大拍《航班蛇患》（Snakes on a Plane）。不。哦，天哪。这让我笑了。他说，是的，我接到电话。我正在拍《航班蛇患》。
Oh, great. Is this another one of the stories you didn't record on your phone last night? Yes, Jenna, it is. All right, thank you. Thank you very much. Let's hear it. When Dave got the call that they
好吧，我知道他们确实不得不调整时间表来配合他。是的，因为他在拍《航班蛇患》。是的，我们只争取到他一天。我们必须在一天内拍完所有托德·帕克的戏份。这样他才能回加拿大继续拍《航班蛇患》。这一集里我最喜欢的场景之一，安吉拉。
wanted him to come in for Todd Packer, guess where he was? Where? He was in Canada filming Snakes on a Plane. No. Oh, my gosh. It just made me laugh. He was like, yeah, I got the call. I was filming Snakes on a Plane.
是的。是当，我有两个，都和托比有关。哦，是的。好的，第一个是当托比透露他必须对性骚扰政策进行审查时。我注意到的一件事是，我觉得托比非常兴奋，因为他终于可以负责某件事了，而且迈克尔别无选择。
Well, I do know that they had to really manipulate the schedule in order to make it work with him. Yeah, because he was filming Snakes on a Plane. Yeah, we got him for one day. We had to film all of the Todd Packer stuff in one day. So he could then go back to Canada and be in Snakes on a Plane. One of my favorite scenes in this episode, Angela.
我不知道，我只是看了几遍那一幕，我觉得我能看到保罗眼中闪过一丝快乐，当他向迈克尔解释他要这样做时，句号。但我还注意到托比的演讲是在办公区进行的。是的。不是在会议室。
Yes. Is when, I have two, they both involve Toby. Oh, yeah. OK, the first is when Toby reveals he has to do a review of the sexual harassment policy. One thing I noticed was I felt like Toby was super excited that he was going to get to run something for a change and that Michael had no choice.
是的。是这样的，我有两个发现，都和托比有关。哦，好的。第一个是托比透露他必须对性骚扰政策进行审查的时候。我注意到的一点是，我觉得托比非常兴奋，因为他终于有机会负责某件事了，而且迈克尔别无选择。
I don't know, I just watched the scene a couple times and I felt like I could see this little happy glint in Paul's eye as he was explaining to Michael that he was going to do this, period. But I also noticed that Toby's presentation happens in the bullpen. Yes. It does not happen in the conference room.
我不知道，我只是看了几遍那个场景，我觉得我能看到保罗在向迈克尔解释他要进行这项工作时，眼里闪过一丝快乐的光芒。但我也注意到托比的演讲是在办公区进行的。是的。不是在会议室里进行的。
And if I remember correctly, it is because we decided that Michael would allow him to have his presentation but not in the conference room. Not in this space. After no circumstances. Maybe I just made that up in my own head. Maybe it's true. The other thing that was interesting to me
如果我没记错的话，是因为我们决定让迈克尔进行他的演讲，但不能在会议室里。不能在这个空间里。绝对不行。也许是我自己脑补的。也许是真的。另一件让我觉得有趣的事情是
that we'd never seen before is Toby does a talking head in front of the vending machine in the break room. Oh. And that is not where our talking heads ever are. They're always in the conference room. Toby is clearly, ever since he got thrown out of the conference room, has not been invited back into the conference room. I watched the deleted scenes for this.
我们以前从未见过，那就是托比在休息室的自动售货机前做了一次采访。哦。那从来都不是我们做采访的地方。它们总是在会议室里。托比显然自从被赶出会议室后，就再也没有被邀请回去过。我看了这一集的删减片段。
And there is a runner of Michael talking heads where he's just talking about how much he hates Toby in different ways. Oh my gosh. It's so good. I have to say, for anybody out there who is wishing there was more office or wishing you could watch more of the office, you actually can.
里面有一连串迈克尔的采访，他只是在谈论他以各种方式讨厌托比。天哪。太棒了。我必须说，对于任何希望有更多《办公室》或者希望你能看更多《办公室》的人来说，你其实可以。
It is the deleted scenes. I have been enjoying them so much. So really, look for them, because just these runner of talking heads from Michael were wonderful. Yeah, I saw some that were pretty amazing. And I wonder out there if the webisodes are available. Oh, yeah. You guys won an Emmy Award for your webisodes.
那就是删减片段。我一直很享受它们。所以一定要找来看看，因为迈克尔的这一连串采访真是太精彩了。是的，我看到了一些非常棒的。我很好奇网上是否有网络短剧。哦，是的。你们的网络短剧还赢得了艾美奖。
I know. We won an Emmy. I remember that. For the accountants. Yeah. I really want some more Pop-Tart. I have it sitting next to me. But I'm afraid it's going to be really loud.
我知道。我们赢得了艾美奖。我记得。为了会计师那一集。是的。我真的很想再吃点果酱馅饼。我就放在旁边。但我怕声音会很大。
We can take a Pop-Tart break if you need to. Angela, you want us to take a break so you can have some Pop-Tart? Is this how you talk to your kids, John? Baby, you want to have some Pop-Tart? Yes, I want to have Pop-Tart. All right, guys, we're going to take a break so Angela can have more of her Pop-Tart. Tell me, can you hear me eating this Pop-Tart one second?
如果你需要的话，我们可以休息一下吃个果酱馅饼。安吉拉，你想让我们休息一下让你吃点果酱馅饼吗？约翰，你平时也是这样跟你的孩子说话的吗？宝贝，你想吃点果酱馅饼吗？是的，我想吃果酱馅饼。好了，伙计们，我们要休息一下，让安吉拉吃她的果酱馅饼。告诉我，你能听到我吃这个果酱馅饼的声音吗，等一下？
Yeah, it's gross. Oh, why is it not gross? It's a Pop-Tart. No one wants to listen to someone chew and swallow. That is maybe something she said. All right, we're going to break. Welcome back, everybody. All right, this is totally off topic.
是的，很恶心。哦，为什么不恶心？这是果酱馅饼。没人想听别人咀嚼和吞咽的声音。那可能是她说过的话。好了，我们要休息了。欢迎回来，各位。好了，这完全跑题了。
But in preparing for this episode, I like to go back and look at some of the old photos that I have. And sort of, it helps me remember things, you know? As you know, I'm a hoarder. I have multiple bins of photos. I found pictures, Jenna, from my first red carpet. It was with you. I was your plus one.
但在准备这一集时，我喜欢回去看看我的一些旧照片。这有助于我回忆起一些事情，你知道吗？如你所知，我是个囤积狂。我有好几个装照片的箱子。珍娜，我找到了我第一次走红毯的照片。是和你一起。我是你的随行人员。
I will never forget this. Uh-huh, you know what it was called? Yeah, pause for style. Not pause button, guys. Pause, like a dog, like a P-A-W-S. Pause for style. Yes, it was a runway show where celebrities walked a catwalk with their dogs.
我永远不会忘记这一点。嗯哼，你知道它叫什么吗？是的，暂停风格（Pause for style）。不是暂停按钮，伙计们。Pause，像狗爪子一样，P-A-W-S。Pause for style。是的，那是一场名人带着他们的狗走猫步的时装秀。
And the dogs were wearing the fashion. So the celebrities were wearing whatever they showed up in. And the dogs were dressed in outfits. It was kind of a hot mess. And the money went to the Humane Society. That's why we went. And you were invited with your dog. I was invited to bring my dog, Wesley.
狗穿着时装。所以名人们穿着他们出席时穿的衣服。而狗则穿着各种服装。那场面有点混乱。钱捐给了人道协会。这就是我们去的原因。你被邀请带着你的狗去。我被邀请带上我的狗，韦斯利。
And Angela, this was your first red carpet. We talked in the Dundee's episode about how I walked the red carpet for 40-year-old Virgin. And I somehow just didn't do it. You skipped it. I don't think it was intentional. I think I just didn't know. I think I just went inside and got my popcorn.
安吉拉，这是你的第一次红毯。我们在《邓迪奖》那一集里谈到我是如何为《四十岁的老处男》走红毯的。我不知怎么就没走。你跳过了。我不认为那是故意的。我想我只是不知道。我想我只是直接走进去拿了我的爆米花。
But for pause for style, you did walk the red carpet. Yeah, I wanted to pick the biggest event possible to my first red carpet. For your coming out. I said, I mean, it's almost like my character. Do you know how many photographers there are? Two. Angela over here. Angela over here.
但对于“Pause for style”，你确实走了红毯。是的，我想为我的第一次红毯选择尽可能大的活动。为了你的首次亮相。我说，我的意思是，这几乎就像我的角色。你知道有多少摄影师吗？两个。安吉拉看这边。安吉拉看这边。
It was like art, like life recreating art or whatever was that saying? Life intimidating, or no, I'm tired. I just spit out my coffee. You said life intimidating art. I am tired, you guys. I am so tired. Art imitating life.
这就像艺术，就像生活重现艺术，或者那句谚语是什么？生活恐吓艺术，或者不，我累了。我刚才把咖啡喷出来了。你说的是生活恐吓艺术。伙计们，我累了。我太累了。艺术模仿生活。
That's what I'm trying to say. Yeah. Not life intimidating art. Oh, good Lord. Anyway, so here we are at pause for style. The big name was Paula Abdul. With her two or three dogs she had. Like three little dogs in outfits. I remember meeting her out by the red carpet.
那才是我要说的。是的。不是生活恐吓艺术。哦，天哪。总之，我们就在“Pause for style”现场。大牌明星是宝拉·阿巴杜。带着她的两三只狗。就像三只穿着衣服的小狗。我记得在红毯边上见过她。
I remember Wesley and her dogs. They all smelled each other as they do. She was very nice. Very nice. I have great photos from this night. I mean, spectacular. I can only imagine. I did my own hair and makeup. This is before I discovered a flat iron.
我记得韦斯利和她的狗。它们像往常一样互相闻了闻。她非常友善。非常友善。我那天晚上拍了很棒的照片。我的意思是，非常壮观。我只能想象。我自己做的头发和化妆。那是在我发现直发夹板之前。
So it's just frizzy, guys. It's just frizzy, down and straight. I bought a tank top at Target. Yep. And I bought one at the Gap. And I layered them. I layered my tank tops. They're both turquoise.
所以头发很毛躁，伙计们。就是毛躁、垂下来、直直的。我在塔吉特百货买了一件背心。是的。我在盖普买了一件。我把它们叠穿在一起。我叠穿了我的背心。它们都是绿松石色的。
Why did I layer two turquoise tank tops? I don't know. And then I bought some white jeans at Target. And this is what I wore. Now I'm gonna say something. You always really do look good in turquoise, Angela. Thank you. It's a great color on you.
我为什么要叠穿两件绿松石色的背心？我不知道。然后我在塔吉特买了一些白色的牛仔裤。这就是我穿的。现在我要说一件事。安吉拉，你穿绿松石色真的很好看。谢谢。这颜色很适合你。
So I think in that way you styled yourself well. Thank you. I think you can tell, because you texted me the photo of you on the red carpet. I think you can tell that how can I say this that you'd never done a red carpet? I mean, you look a little bit stiff. How can I say this?
所以我认为在那方面你把自己打扮得很好。谢谢。我想你看得出来，因为你给我发了你在红毯上的照片。我想你看得出来，我该怎么说呢，你从来没走过红毯？我的意思是，你看上去有点僵硬。我该怎么说呢？
I love how delicately you're trying to put this. Jenna, it's like, you know how if you stand and you put your hands on your hip? Yeah. What if you decided to stand but do your legs like spread way too far apart? Yeah. And then instead of putting your hands on your hip
我喜欢你试图委婉表达的方式。珍娜，就像，你知道如果你站着，把手放在臀部上？是的。如果你决定站着，但双腿分得太开会怎样？是的。然后你没有把手放在臀部上，
and your five one guys, your five one, you decide to put them on your mid thigh? Yeah, kind of like above your leg. Almost like you're doing a squat. Yeah. Like, and then you smiled a camera. That's what I did. That's what she did.
而且你只有五英尺一英寸，伙计们，你只有五英尺一英寸，你决定把它们放在大腿中部？是的，就像在腿上方。几乎就像你在做深蹲。是的。就像，然后你对着镜头微笑。我就是这么做的。她就是这么做的。
Yeah, that's what I did. Why did I stand like that? Listen, you guys, we didn't know anything about red carpets. We didn't have anyone advising us. Well, do you remember Angela? After this event, we saw the pictures and we decided we needed to get better at this. Yeah.
是的，我就是这么做的。我为什么要那样站着？听着，伙计们，我们对红毯一无所知。没有人给我们建议。好吧，安吉拉，你还记得吗？这次活动之后，我们看到了照片，我们决定我们需要在这方面做得更好。是的。
And so, and then do you remember that I had read somewhere that the reason that Mary, Kate and Ashley Olson always look so cute on the red carpet is because they say the word prune while the photographers are taking their photograph. The idea is that it makes you look like really like pouty and sexy.
然后你还记得我曾在某处读到过，玛丽-凯特和阿什利·奥尔森在红毯上总是看起来那么可爱的秘诀，是因为她们在摄影师拍照时会说“prune”（梅子）这个词。这个想法是它能让你看起来非常嘟嘴和性感。
So we decided at our next red carpet that we were gonna say prune. Yeah. The whole time. So it was like prune, prune, prune. They're the worst photos of me like that exist. We look so. I look constipated.
所以我们在下一次红毯上决定我们要说“prune”。是的。全程都在说。所以就像是prune，prune，prune。那是我存在的最糟糕的照片。我们看起来太……我看起来便秘了。
It was such a horrible idea. I thought I looked just looked angry. I looked like, I look like I need to poop. That's what, I just look miserable. Oh my gosh, Angela. I think back on all of our bright ideas. Our bright ideas, I think it's fair to say these are all your ideas.
那真是个糟糕的主意。我觉得我看起来只是很生气。我看起来像，我看起来像需要大便。就是那样，我看起来很痛苦。天哪，安吉拉。回想我们所有的好主意。我们的好主意，我觉得公平地说这些都是你的主意。
Why did you go along with them? I don't know. I don't, you're very persuasive. I don't know. I just was like, okay, I'll walk up and pretend to fake laugh as I walk up to people. Okay, I'll say prune, okay. All right, what should we,
你为什么要跟着做？我不知道。我不知道，你很有说服力。我不知道。我只是觉得，好吧，我会走过去，假装大笑，当我走向人们时。好吧，我会说prune，好吧。好了，我们应该，
we should get back to this episode. Okay, let's do it. Oh, I have a tidbit. Great, what's your tidbit? I think I see John Krasinski about to break at 16 minutes, one second. So Michael cannot say that's what she said anymore. Yes, he comes out of his office.
我们应该回到这一集。好的，我们开始吧。哦，我有一个小花絮。太好了，你的小花絮是什么？我想我看到约翰·卡拉辛斯基在16分01秒时快要笑场了。所以迈克尔不能再说“That's what she said”了。是的，他从办公室走出来。
He makes a grand announcement. He's retiring from comedy. Yes. And he's not gonna say, you know, Jim is like, not even that's what she said. And he's like, nope, I remember filming this scene. I remember filming this too. And Steve, as Michael, when he breaks
他做了一个隆重的宣布。他要从喜剧界退休了。是的。他不会再说，你知道，吉姆就像，甚至不是“That's what she said”。他说，不，我记得拍摄这一幕。我也记得拍摄这一幕。史蒂夫，作为迈克尔，当他笑场时，
and he goes, that's what she said. His laugh is so huge and giddy and contagious. And he's so happy and pleased with himself that we literally almost started to all laugh ourselves and you catch it in John for just a second. Really? Yeah, do you want to see? Well, also as Steve is leaving
他说“That's what she said”。他的笑声是那么大、那么轻快、那么有感染力。他对自己感到如此快乐和满意，以至于我们真的差点自己也笑了起来，你在约翰身上捕捉到了那一瞬间。真的吗？是的，你想看吗？好吧，史蒂夫离开时，
and he's being pushed back into his office by Jan and the lawyer, he blows a kiss. He's so happy. But look at John's face at 16 minutes, one second. Sam, can you pull that up? That included, that's what she said. Yes. Wow, that is really hard.
他被简和律师推回办公室，他送了一个飞吻。他太高兴了。但看看约翰在16分01秒时的表情。萨姆，你能调出来吗？那包括了“That's what she said”。是的。哇，那真的很难。
You really think you can go all day long? Well, you always left me satisfied and smiling, so. That's what she said. Michael, Michael, Michael, Michael, Michael, please. Look at John, look at John. Do you see how he puts his hand in front of his face? That's what he would do when he was starting to laugh. Yes, for sure.
你真的认为你可以整天都这样吗？嗯，你总是让我感到满足和微笑，所以。That's what she said。迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔，迈克尔，求你了。看约翰，看约翰。你看到他怎么把手放在脸前了吗？那就是他开始笑时会做的动作。是的，肯定的。
Yeah. That, I mean, and that is just Steve, because he is a master. He is such a master at like any kind of like big emotional moment. We've talked about how it's really hard to fake love. It's really hard to fake laugh. Yeah.
是的。那，我的意思是，那只是史蒂夫，因为他是一位大师。他在处理任何那种大的情感时刻时都是大师。我们谈过假装爱是多么困难。假装笑是多么困难。是的。
It's harder than fake crying. Oh, for sure. Steve is one of the best at the fake laugh. For sure. So we skipped something that I definitely want to go back to. Okay, what? When Michael crashes Toby's presentation and he walks in with the blow-up doll.
这比假装哭更难。哦，肯定的。史蒂夫是假笑方面最棒的人之一。肯定的。所以我们跳过了一些我绝对想回去讲的内容。好的，什么？当迈克尔闯入托比的演讲时，他带着充气娃娃走了进来。
Oh, yeah. Do you remember the days and days of those guys trying to figure out which blow-up doll should be the blow-up doll? Oh, yeah. So it was like, should she have on an outfit? Should she be wearing underwear? Should she be wearing a bikini?
哦，是的。你还记得那些家伙花了好几天时间试图弄清楚哪个充气娃娃应该作为那个充气娃娃吗？哦，是的。所以就像，她应该穿什么衣服？她应该穿内衣吗？她应该穿比基尼吗？
They had a variety of blow-up dolls. This is a weird thing about working on a television show or in a movie or anything. Are the really just very matter-of-fact discussions about odd things. I remember seeing our props master and Greg and I think it must have been BJ and Ken Quapas, but like there was a group of people
他们有各种各样的充气娃娃。这是在电视节目或电影或任何东西上工作的一件奇怪的事情。是对奇怪的事情进行非常实事求是的讨论。我记得看到我们的道具师和格雷格，我想一定是BJ和肯·夸帕斯，但有一群人
looking at different blow-up dolls and having a very matter-of-fact discussion about what is funniest. There was one that had a more open mouth. I remember that one. That was it. We nixed that one. That one was so off-putting.
看着不同的充气娃娃，并就什么最有趣进行了非常实事求是的讨论。有一个嘴巴张得更大的。我记得那个。就是它。我们否决了那个。那个太让人反感了。
Yeah. But the other thing too is we'd walk on set and backstage we would have like props and things. And I remember walking past like five blow-up dolls every morning for like a week. I was like, what is our life? And then Michael has a lot of comedy with that blow-up doll. I love that part when we're jumping around here,
是的。但另一件事是，我们会走进片场，在后台我们会有道具之类的东西。我记得有一周每天早上走过五个充气娃娃。我在想，我们的生活是什么？然后迈克尔和那个充气娃娃有很多喜剧互动。我喜欢我们在这里跳来跳去的那部分，
but when Pam's mom does finally come in and Michael walks out of his office and like chucks it out the door in like a grandiose statement. But also in the scene with Jan, it's hiding up on top of his credenza. And Jim has this talking head with the blow-up doll. So the blow-up doll got a lot of play in this episode. It's very important that we pick the right one.
但当帕姆的妈妈终于进来时，迈克尔走出办公室，以一种宏大的声明把它扔出门外。但在与简的那一幕中，它藏在他的餐具柜上。吉姆和那个充气娃娃有一个采访。所以充气娃娃在这一集中戏份很多。选择正确的那个非常重要。
Yeah. Bit of a character. The blow-up doll was gonna be featured in those conversations were warranted. Okay, something else I wanna mention, unrelated to the blow-up doll. When Michael takes over the sexual harassment seminar, there is a great deleted scene
是的。有点像个角色。充气娃娃将成为那些对话中的主角，这是有道理的。好的，还有一件事我想提一下，与充气娃娃无关。当迈克尔接管性骚扰研讨会时，有一个很棒的删减片段，
where Michael goes on this runner. Did you see it where he says it's about him and Pam? And I remember shooting the scene and I couldn't get through it. Not the bathtub thing. No, not the bathtub thing. This was a different runner where Michael says, all right, take for example, Pam and I are dating.
迈克尔在那儿进行了一连串的表演。你看到了吗？他说这是关于他和帕姆的。我记得拍摄那一幕时，我无法坚持下去。不是浴缸那件事。不，不是浴缸那件事。这是另一段，迈克尔说，好吧，举个例子，帕姆和我在约会。
And I say that would never happen. He goes, no, it's happening. Pam and I are dating. And I'm like, I'm engaged. She's like, Roy died. And I'm like, even still. And he's like, then I would kill you. He's the now, Roy and Pam are both dead.
我说那永远不会发生。他说，不，正在发生。帕姆和我在约会。我说我订婚了。他说罗伊死了。我说，即使这样。他说，那我就杀了你。他说现在罗伊和帕姆都死了。
Look at what sexual harassment seminar got us. I did see that. It's just like a very funny thing. I actually did see that in a montage. That is hilarious. Yes. And then just Michael just like really pushing this like hypothetical situation where he and Pam are dating.
看看性骚扰研讨会给我们带来了什么。我确实看到了。这只是一个非常有趣的事情。我确实在蒙太奇里看到了。那太搞笑了。是的。然后迈克尔真的在推销这种他和帕姆在约会的假设情况。
And that comes up every once in a while. Every once in a while, there's a little thing where Pam has to deal with Michael's hypothetical that there's a world where maybe they're dating. There was clearly a time he had a crush on you. I guess so. And he finally just gave up. And what about in that same scene, Phyllis's line
这种情况偶尔会出现。偶尔会有一点小插曲，帕姆必须处理迈克尔关于他们可能在约会的世界的假设。显然有一段时间他暗恋你。我想是吧。然后他终于放弃了。那在同一幕中，菲利斯的台词呢，
where she asks if you have to disclose one night stands. No, they talk about you have to just report a relationship to HR and she goes, all relationships? Even a one night stand? Yes. Is she talking about a previous one night stand or a future one night stand? I don't know, but John's looked a camera as Jim
她问你是否必须披露一夜情。不，他们谈论你必须向人力资源部报告一段关系，她说，所有的关系？甚至是一夜情？是的。她在谈论之前的一夜情还是未来的一夜情？我不知道，但约翰作为吉姆看向镜头的那个表情，
when she says that is so gold. That is classic Jim look to camera. Let's talk about my other favorite Toby scene. What's that? At the end of Toby's seminar, he says, if you have any questions, you can come speak to me. And Dwight goes to him and they have that big long conversation.
当她说那句话时，真是太经典了。那是典型的吉姆看向镜头的表情。让我们谈谈我另一个最喜欢的托比场景。是什么？在托比的研讨会结束时，他说，如果你有任何问题，你可以来找我谈。德怀特去找他，他们进行了那场漫长的对话。
Yes. Where Dwight is basically asking about female anatomy and sex. Yeah, it starts around 12 minutes. I have it on a card. A lot of people asked about that scene. Was it scripted? Was it improvised?
是的。德怀特基本上是在问关于女性解剖结构和性的问题。是的，大约在12分钟左右开始。我把它写在卡片上了。很多人问过那一幕。是写好的剧本吗？还是即兴创作的？
So when Dwight asks, where is the clitoris? That is where the scene was supposed to end. So everything after that, those were all reigns improvisations and they shot that scene for about two hours. They shot it for so long. And also Paul, as Toby was improvising as well. Yes. And I thought he had such a great line when he was like,
所以当德怀特问，阴蒂在哪里？那一幕本该在那里结束。所以在那之后的一切，那些都是雷恩的即兴创作，他们拍摄那一幕拍了大约两个小时。他们拍了太久了。而且保罗作为托比也在即兴发挥。是的。我觉得他有一句很棒的台词，当他说……
well, you know, when you're both more comfortable. You know, he has this great line. And I wrote, who is Dwight asking the advice for? Right. Is this the beginning of Dwight and Angela? I wondered the same thing. And people pointed this out. Dwight seems very comfortable around women and hot girl.
嗯，你知道，当你们俩都更自在的时候。你知道，他有句很棒的台词。我当时写道，德怀特是在向谁寻求建议呢？对吧。这是德怀特和安吉拉的开始吗？我也在想同样的事情。人们也指出了这一点。德怀特在女性和辣妹面前似乎非常自在。
He doesn't seem to have any of these hangups necessarily. And then now suddenly in this episode, he's revealing maybe the truth, which is that he doesn't know so many things about women. Well, I also think that he might actually have a woman, finally, who might be interested in doing those things with him. Perhaps. And he's realized he doesn't have the skill set for it.
他似乎并不一定有什么顾虑。但现在突然在这一集里，他可能揭示了真相，那就是他其实对女性了解得并不多。嗯，我也认为他可能终于有了一个可能愿意和他做那些事情的女人。也许吧。而他意识到自己并没有相应的技能。
Ah, ah, I think that's what it is. Oh, Angela. What? This is the first episode where we finally see the real outside of the Dunder Mifflin that we will come to know and love. Oh, when Michael goes down to get jokes? Yes, when he goes down to meet the warehouse guys.
啊，啊，我想就是这样。哦，安吉拉。什么？这是我们第一次看到邓德·米夫林公司之外的真实场景，也就是我们后来所熟知和喜爱的那些。哦，是迈克尔下去找笑话的时候吗？是的，当他下去见仓库员工的时候。
Will you see it? Will you see the parking lot? When Ryan takes Todd Packard down. But then you really see him come down through the lobby and outside and around the corner. And he's talking to all the warehouse guys. I thought that was so cool. I did, too.
你会看到吗？你会看到停车场吗？当瑞安带托德·帕卡德下去的时候。但随后你真的看到他穿过大厅，走到外面，绕过拐角。他在和所有的仓库员工交谈。我觉得那太酷了。我也这么觉得。
I thought it was great. So the point of that scene, because I was texting with BJ about this, the point of that scene was that Michael would go down to ask for jokes. And then the guys in the warehouse would actually start sexually harassing Michael. So that's the point they start commenting on his appearance and his pants and his lack of package.
我觉得那很棒。所以那一幕的重点是——因为我当时正和BJ发短信讨论这件事——那一幕的重点是迈克尔下去寻求笑话。然后仓库里的那些人实际上开始对迈克尔进行性骚扰。所以重点是他们开始评论他的外表、他的裤子以及他那方面的不行。
Yes, and all that sort of stuff. And yet somehow this does not land on Michael. He learns nothing from being the recipient of harassment. It just, he's just frustrated they didn't give him a good joke he could use. But then later, all those same warehouse guys are called up to the conference room. And they have to watch a sexual harassment training video.
是的，诸如此类。然而不知何故，这一切并没有让迈克尔有所触动。他并没有从遭受骚扰这件事中学到任何东西。他只是因为他们没给他提供一个好笑话而感到沮丧。但后来，所有那些仓库员工都被叫到了会议室。他们不得不观看一段性骚扰培训视频。
But did you notice it's all those guys and Kevin? Yes. Well, here's what I think. I think Kevin is kind of like that teenage kid who, if there's any chance he might see someone in a bra, maybe side boob. Oh, he's in that. He's in that.
但你注意到了吗？里面全是那些家伙，还有凯文？是的。嗯，我是这么想的。我觉得凯文就像那种十几岁的孩子，如果有一丁点机会能看到别人穿胸罩，哪怕是侧面的乳沟，哦，他绝对会参与其中。他绝对会参与。
He's the one that does the milk joke about your mom. Like he's kind of like, I feel like the kid who is like excited to maybe see anything go down. Well, I think that sexual harassment video is amazing. We shot that. That's not a real sexual harassment video. Joel wrote in and asked, did the actors in the sexual harassment video know
他就是那个讲关于你妈妈的牛奶笑话的人。我觉得他就像那种因为可能看到什么事情发生而感到兴奋的孩子。嗯，我觉得那个性骚扰视频太棒了。那是我们拍的。那不是真正的性骚扰视频。乔尔写信问，性骚扰视频里的演员是否知道
they were auditioning for a sitcom, or did they think it was just an educational video? That's an awesome question. That is an awesome question. They knew that they were going to appear on the office, but they were told to pretend like they were making a real educational video. They did a phenomenal job.
他们是在为情景喜剧试镜，还是以为那只是一个教育视频？这是一个很棒的问题。这确实是一个很棒的问题。他们知道自己会出现在《办公室》里，但他们被告知要假装是在制作一个真正的教育视频。他们表现得非常出色。
Those guest actors were amazing. They were amazing. And we shot that in the actual writer's offices. All right, I found it hilarious that when Michael is in the scene with Jan and the corporate lawyer, I feel like this is the first time Michael realizes that he's upper management. Oh, and he's so proud.
那些客串演员太棒了。他们太棒了。而且我们是在真正的编剧办公室里拍摄的。好吧，我觉得很有趣的是，当迈克尔和简以及公司律师在一起时，我觉得这是迈克尔第一次意识到自己是高层管理人员。哦，他感到非常自豪。
He's so proud. He's so proud of himself, because he's hired James P. Albini, the guy from the bus stop to be his lawyer. I love that scene. Actually, that's a really great scene to watch if you want to like nerd out on the camera work and the way that the camera helps tell the story on the office.
他非常自豪。他为自己感到非常自豪，因为他雇佣了詹姆斯·P·阿尔比尼，那个在公交车站遇到的家伙做他的律师。我喜欢那个场景。事实上，如果你想深入研究摄像技术以及摄像机如何帮助讲述《办公室》里的故事，那是一个非常值得一看的场景。
Because that whole entrance of Michael's lawyer, the way Michael's lawyer looks directly at camera and gives a little plug for his business, is pretty great. But the camera work in that scene is really incredible. Also, in that scene, Toby, where he's sitting, he's not been invited to sit sort of in the circle. Yeah, he's off against the wall. It's a great scene to watch, just watch Toby.
因为迈克尔律师的整个出场，他直视镜头并为自己的业务做了一点宣传的方式，真是太棒了。但那一幕的摄影工作真的很不可思议。另外，在那个场景里，托比坐的地方，他并没有被邀请坐在圈子里。是的，他靠在墙边。这是一个很棒的场景，只要盯着托比看就行了。
And Toby has- The whole scene is pretty delicious. And Toby has a great snarky moment in that scene, because Jan's like, Michael, are you going to have to watch the video again? And he's like, I watched the video. And Toby goes, he talked through most of it. Yes.
托比有——整个场景非常精彩。托比在那个场景里有一个很棒的讽刺时刻，因为简说，迈克尔，你还要再看一遍录像吗？他说，我看过录像了。托比就说，他大部分时间都在说话。是的。
Toby, Toby throwing him under the bus. So now we finally have to talk about the scene where Michael stands up to Todd Packer, otherwise known as the Boner scene. The Boner scene. Todd Packer is making this joke about someone attending a Nymphomaniacs convention. Yeah, and all the gals are like perfect tins,
托比，托比把他推向了风口浪尖。所以现在我们终于要谈谈迈克尔站出来对抗托德·帕克的那一幕了，也就是所谓的“硬了”场景。“硬了”场景。托德·帕克在讲一个关于有人参加性瘾者大会的笑话。是的，所有的女孩都像完美的罐头，
except for this one gal. And he points to Phyllis. And then Kevin says, like Phyllis. And then, Phyllis looks really sad. Oh, so sad. So hurt. So hurt. And it's awkward.
除了这一个女孩。他指着菲利斯。然后凯文说，像菲利斯。然后，菲利斯看起来真的很伤心。哦，太伤心了。太受伤了。太受伤了。而且很尴尬。
First of all, do we need a joke about a Nymphomaniac convention? Todd Packer, thank you very much. And Michael sees that Phyllis is hurt, and he says that that was inappropriate. He says something. But then Todd Packer challenges him. And he's like, I mean, Kevin, Kevin,
首先，我们需要一个关于性瘾者大会的笑话吗？托德·帕克，非常感谢你。迈克尔看到菲利斯受伤了，他说这很不合适。他说了一些话。但随后托德·帕克挑战了他。他说，我是说，凯文，凯文，
you should not say those things about Phyllis. And then he goes on this whole speech about how Phyllis is great and how he loves Phyllis. She's like a grandmother to them. And she says, I mean, Michael, we're the same age. We went to high school together. I love this. I love that.
你不应该那样说菲利斯。然后他发表了一整篇演讲，说菲利斯有多棒，他有多爱菲利斯。她就像他们的祖母一样。她说，我是说，迈克尔，我们同岁。我们一起上的高中。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。
And that fact comes back to haunt Michael all the time. She is constantly reminding him in the series that they went to high school together. It's a really sweet scene. And he hugs Phyllis, and then he says the only thing he's afraid of is getting a boner. A boner? And then Phyllis' face, her reaction,
而这个事实一直困扰着迈克尔。她在剧集中不断提醒他，他们是一起上高中的。这是一个非常甜蜜的场景。他拥抱了菲利斯，然后他说他唯一害怕的就是“硬了”。“硬了”？然后菲利斯的脸，她的反应，
is what made it for me. It made that whole scene. It really did. It really did. And I think that there was this way where, I don't know, do you think Michael's redeemed in that moment a little bit? Because he stands up for his group a little bit? He does.
对我来说是点睛之笔。它成就了整个场景。确实如此。确实如此。而且我认为在某种程度上，我不知道，你认为迈克尔在那一刻得到了一点救赎吗？因为他为他的团队挺身而出了一点点？是的。
I think it's definitely the first time he has stood up to Todd Packer. And you can tell, because when you see Todd Packer's face, he's like, oh, man, they really got to you. And Michael's like, no, I got to them, like whatever that means. But I think it's the first time he stood up to him. And even though it's a very small way,
我认为这绝对是他第一次站出来对抗托德·帕克。你可以看出来，因为当你看到托德·帕克的脸时，他就像是，哦，伙计，他们真的影响到你了。而迈克尔就像是，不，是我影响了他们，不管这意味着什么。但我认为这是他第一次站出来对抗他。尽管这是一种非常微小的方式，
I think it's that moment, once again, where this is our writers trying to give Michael a little bit of a growth moment. What? Angela, you just referred to the boner scene as the scene where the writers give Michael a little bit of a growth moment. Oh, no.
我认为这就是那一刻，再一次，这是我们的编剧试图给迈克尔一点成长时刻。什么？安吉拉，你刚才把“硬了”场景称为编剧给迈克尔一点成长时刻的场景。哦，不。
That's perfect. That's perfect. OK, now let's talk about the scene with Pam's mom. We said a little bit about this earlier, Angela. You expressed your disgust that this is her first visit. OK, I just am saying, like, where have you been, mom? That's all. I get it.
这太完美了。这太完美了。好吧，现在让我们谈谈帕姆妈妈的场景。安吉拉，我们之前稍微提过一点。你表达了对这是她第一次访问的厌恶。好吧，我只是想说，妈妈，你去哪儿了？就是这样。我明白了。
I get it. But there is more to say here. Yeah. So first of all, Pam's mom was played by Shannon Cochran. And a lot of people wrote in and said, what the heck is up with Pam's mom? Why is she played by one person in this episode? And then another person later on in the show.
我明白了。但这里还有更多要说的。是的。所以首先，帕姆的妈妈是由香农·科克伦扮演的。很多人写信问，帕姆的妈妈到底怎么了？为什么她在这一集中由一个人扮演？然后在剧集的后期又换成了另一个人。
I will tell you, we wanted Shannon Cochran to come back. We cast her as Pam's mom. We intended for her to always play Pam's mom. But then we didn't need Pam's mom for a really long time. Shannon got a theater contract. She was a touring theater actress with Rain. Her and I had a lot to discuss. Oh, look at her.
我跟你说，我们本来想让香农·科克伦回来。我们选她演帕姆的妈妈。我们本来打算一直让她演帕姆的妈妈。但后来很长一段时间都不需要帕姆的妈妈这个角色。香农接了一份戏剧合同。她是一位巡回演出的戏剧演员，演的是《雨》。她和我有很多话要聊。哦，看她。
Yes. Theater pedigree. Fancy theater people. That's right. And she wasn't available. And so we had to recast her for those later episodes. And it was a really weird thing, because the integrity of our show was so important to us.
是的。戏剧背景。高级的戏剧圈人士。没错。她没档期。所以我们不得不为后来的剧集重新选角。这真的很奇怪，因为我们非常看重剧集的完整性。
There was this rule for a very long time that we couldn't do any stunt casting. Yeah. I don't know if people know what that means. Yeah. Explain it. Yeah. So stunt casting means when you bring on a guest star
很长一段时间里，我们有一条规定，不能搞噱头选角。是的。我不知道大家知不知道这是什么意思。是的。解释一下。好的。噱头选角是指当你请来一位客串明星时，
and they're a big name guest star. Now, of course, obviously, in later years, we broke this rule. Will Ferrell, Kathy Bates, James Speter. Idris Elba. Yes, exactly. Timothy Oliphant. On and on.
而且他们是大牌客串明星。当然，后来几年我们打破了这个规定。威尔·法瑞尔、凯西·贝茨、詹姆斯·斯派德。伊德里斯·艾尔巴。是的，没错。蒂莫西·奥利芬特。等等等等。
Yeah. But for a long time, we had this rule against stunt casting. And this kind of fell into that. Like, once somebody was established to play a character, they were that person, or they didn't come back. The reason we broke the rule with Pam's mom in recasting is because the writers came up with a storyline
是的。但很长一段时间里，我们都有禁止噱头选角的规定。这事儿有点沾边。就像一旦有人被确定扮演某个角色，他们就是那个人，否则就不会再回来。我们之所以在帕姆妈妈的选角上打破规定，是因为编剧想出了一个剧情，
that Michael would date Pam's mom. Do you remember that? How could I forget that? Right, I know. And Pam ends up slapping Michael. But this storyline idea was just too good to pass up. So they decided to recast. And I hope that helps people with the Whole Two Moms
迈克尔会和帕姆的妈妈约会。你还记得吗？我怎么可能忘得了？对，我知道。帕姆最后打了迈克尔一巴掌。但这个剧情点子太棒了，不容错过。所以他们决定重新选角。我希望这能帮大家解答关于“两个妈妈”的问题。
question. So I want to talk a little bit about the scene when Pam's mom finally arrives and you see Roy enter. Oh, my god, in his outfit with his hair slicked down. His sweater. And he does that little dance to charm Pam's mom. So I'm going to let you in on a little bit more of my actor prep here.
所以我想聊聊帕姆的妈妈终于到达，然后你看到罗伊进来的那一幕。天哪，他那身打扮，头发抹得油光锃亮。还有他的毛衣。他跳起那段小舞来讨好帕姆的妈妈。所以我要向你们透露更多关于我的演员准备工作。
And he asked her what music she wants. Yes. OK, what is it? Well, you know, I had my Pam document. And I was always asking myself questions about Pam that I thought were a mystery and I would answer them. Wait, I need to clarify for everyone. Jenna's Pam document wasn't given to her by Greg Daniels
他问她想听什么音乐。是的。好吧，是什么？嗯，你知道，我有我的“帕姆文档”。我总是问自己一些关于帕姆的问题，我觉得这些问题很神秘，然后我会回答它们。等等，我需要向大家澄清一下。珍娜的“帕姆文档”不是格雷格·丹尼尔斯
or any writers or producers. This was a document that Jenna made herself for her character. These are the kinds of things you learn in theater school, Angela. You can suck it. These are the things we're encouraged to do. I took some theater. I took theater classes.
或者任何编剧或制片人给她的。这是珍娜自己为她的角色制作的文档。安吉拉，这些就是你在戏剧学校学到的东西。去你的吧。这些是我们被鼓励去做的事情。我学过一些戏剧。我上过戏剧课。
You know, just trained theater actors. I took classes at H.B. Studios in New York City with Carol Rosenfeld, who was a protege of Uda Hagen. Thank you very much. All right. That's some pedigree. Thank you. All right.
你知道，就是受过训练的戏剧演员。我在纽约市的H.B.工作室上过卡罗尔·罗森菲尔德的课，她是乌塔·哈根的学生。非常感谢。好吧。那可是很有背景的。谢谢。好的。
I got a blessing. Well, in my document, I had asked myself the question, how did Pam and Roy end up together anyway? So I've answered sort of why I think they're still together, but how did they end up together? They seem so mismatched to me. Here was my backstory. Pam's family owned an appliance shop
我得到了祝福。嗯，在我的文档里，我问过自己一个问题，帕姆和罗伊到底是怎么走到一起的？所以我回答了为什么我觉得他们还在一起，但他们是怎么走到一起的？我觉得他们看起来很不般配。这是我的背景故事。帕姆的家人拥有一家电器店，
in downtown Scranton, like in the town square. And Roy, in high school, got a job working at the appliance store. And he was a great worker. He was very charming. As in the Roy you just saw here in the sweater. And so that was how their worlds collided. Because Pam was probably this little nerdy art student
在斯克兰顿市中心，就像在城镇广场那样。罗伊在高中时在电器店找了份工作。他是个很棒的员工。他非常有魅力。就像你刚才看到的穿毛衣的罗伊那样。这就是他们世界碰撞的方式。因为帕姆在高中时可能是一个书呆子气的艺术生，
in high school, so I couldn't figure out how did she meet Roy. Who was probably a jock. Yeah, and this was how. He was very charming, and he asked her out, and they started dating. But because he worked there, the families became very enmeshed.
所以我搞不懂她是怎么认识罗伊的。他可能是一个运动员。是的，就是这样。他很有魅力，他约她出去，然后他们就开始约会了。但因为他在那里工作，两家人的关系变得非常紧密。
They would barbecue together. So this is why and how she kind of can't get out of this relationship, even though now it's clear it's a mismatch. It's because the families are so cojoined. And do you think that Pam decided not to work at the appliance store and go out, branch out, and then Roy followed her to the warehouse?
他们会一起烧烤。所以这就是为什么她有点无法摆脱这段关系，尽管现在很明显他们不般配。是因为两家人的关系太紧密了。你觉得帕姆是不是决定不去电器店工作，而是出去闯荡，然后罗伊跟着她去了仓库？
Oh my gosh, Angela, I don't know. But I feel like I'm going to go back and put that in my document right now. Because here's Pam, like, OK, I'm not going to work at the family business. I need some space. I need to figure out who I am. Yes!
天哪，安吉拉，我不知道。但我觉得我现在就要回去把这一点加进我的文档里。因为帕姆在这里，就像是，好吧，我不会在家族企业工作了。我需要一些空间。我需要弄清楚我是谁。是的！
And then Roy's like, hey, I got a job at that warehouse. We'll be able to see each other every day. Oh my gosh. I find it interesting that Pam eats in the break room with Jim and not in the warehouse with Roy. Now we see Roy sometimes eat there. Yeah, they don't eat lunch together, do they? Not very often.
然后罗伊说，嘿，我在那个仓库找了份工作。我们每天都能见面。天哪。我觉得很有趣的是，帕姆和吉姆在休息室吃饭，而不是和罗伊在仓库吃。现在我们有时会看到罗伊在那里吃。是的，他们不常一起吃午饭，对吧？不常。
And then Pam's mom has the moment in this episode where she whispers, which one is Jim? And you see John Krasinski's face. He's all pleased that he knows now that Pam. And by the way, in Casino Night, we know Pam calls her mom on the phone to share about what happened in the parking lot. Well, I just love the moment.
然后帕姆的妈妈在这一集里低声问，哪一个是吉姆？你看到了约翰·卡拉辛斯基的表情。他很高兴，因为他现在知道帕姆……顺便说一下，在赌场之夜，我们知道帕姆给妈妈打电话分享停车场发生的事情。嗯，我真的很喜欢那一刻。
And John played it so well, where he sees his opportunity to introduce himself to Pam's mom. And he gets up the courage. And he walks over right as Roy walks in. And he just quickly takes a piece of candy and goes back to his desk. And that kind of broke my heart for him. Lastly, from Dave Keckner, who plays Todd Packer.
约翰演得太好了，他看到了向帕姆妈妈介绍自己的机会。他鼓起勇气。就在罗伊走进来的时候，他走了过去。他只是迅速拿了一块糖，然后回到了自己的座位上。那一幕让我为他感到心碎。最后，来自扮演托德·帕克的戴夫·科克纳，
He said, Ang, please let everyone know I am nothing like Todd Packer in real life. Oh, and it's true, everyone. I know. Dave is just a sweet, sweet, sweetheart, father of five. I know. And he said, he goes, I just wish you and Jenna all the best. This is such a great idea.
他说，安吉拉，请告诉大家，我在现实生活中一点也不像托德·帕克。哦，这是真的，大家。我知道。戴夫是一个非常非常甜心的人，五个孩子的父亲。我知道。他说，他希望你和珍娜一切都好。这真是个好主意。
I just love it as a fan of the show. It's got to be hard to believe that he is not like Todd Packer for some people. To imagine that if you met him, he is just the warmest, nicest, wonderful gentleman. I know. Yeah, I think sometimes you get known as this character, but he's nothing like that.
作为节目的粉丝，我真的很喜欢。对有些人来说，很难相信他不像托德·帕克。想象一下，如果你见到他，他只是一个最温暖、最友善、最棒的绅士。我知道。是的，我觉得有时候你会因为这个角色而出名，但他一点也不像那样。
I'm nothing like Angela Martin. This is true. You're a little bit like Pam. I am. All right, guys, that was sexual harassment. That was sexual harassment. We did it. Next week is Office Olympics with special guest
我一点也不像安吉拉·马丁。这是真的。你有点像帕姆。我是。好了，伙计们，那是性骚扰。那是性骚扰。我们做到了。下周是办公室奥运会，特别嘉宾是
director, Paul Feig. He is the best dressed man in show business, for sure. Go to his Instagram. It is delightful. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher, our sound engineer is Sam
导演保罗·费格。他绝对是演艺圈穿衣最有品位的人。去看看他的Instagram。非常令人愉快。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的制片人是科迪·费舍尔，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·
Kiefer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Gratton. For ad-free versions of the show and our bonus episodes Candy Bag, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. And don't forget to like, comment, and subscribe. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
基弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·格拉顿的《橡胶树》。如需收听无广告版本的节目和我们的奖励剧集《糖果袋》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。如需免费试用Stitcher Premium一个月，请使用代码Office。别忘了点赞、评论和订阅。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。